this video was brought to you by legal
eagles copyright course calm giving all
creators the tools they need to fight
bogus copyright claims cop is here and
it's going to change YouTube forever is
your channel going to be affected or is
it going to affect a channel that you
love and if it is what can be done about
it this is a complicated area of the law
and some of the bad news is true but I
also haven't seen any one commentator
get things a hundred percent right and
in some respects we don't have some of
the answers that we need for creators or
viewers of YouTube but the bottom line
is that YouTube is going to change
forever
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because Coppa is complicated in
this particular situation with the
intersection of Coppa and YouTube deals
with federal law regulatory rulemaking
federal lawsuits settlements between
YouTube and the FTC and YouTube's
internal policies and creators are right
in the middle of everything but today
we're going to discuss everything that
you need to know about köppen how we
found ourselves in this situation this
will probably be a longer video because
we're gonna look at the actual language
of the law I haven't seen really anyone
take a deep dive into the relevant
language that's at issue because it's
really really complicated and it's
really important and some of these
things you can't dumb down because the
effects are so dire we're going to talk
about if Coppa applies to your channel
or if it applies to channels that you
love to watch and if Coppa does apply
we're going to talk about what creators
can and should do as a result we're
gonna talk about why you should care
whether you have a YouTube channel or
not and we're gonna talk about what
everyone can do whether you are a
channel operator or just a viewer of
YouTube to deal with some of the more
onerous regulations of Coppa and what we
can do to make sure that it is more
narrowly tailored to the needs of
channel creators and the audience on
YouTube so first what is kapa kapa is
the Children's Online Privacy Protection
Act it was passed in 1998 under the
Clinton administration became effective
in April of 2000 the Federal Trade
Commission is the regulatory body that
is in charge of actually enforcing Coppa
now the purpose of Coppa was and is to
protect children from stress
and being unfairly targeted by
advertisers it's to prevent kids from
posting their information like their
address phone number and social security
online without parental consent so why
does Coppa exist cough it was created to
put parents back in control of kids
providing information online it was
enacted into law after the FTC issued a
report called the kids comm letter where
the FTC had investigated a now-defunct
website called kids come from the late
90s aimed at children which required
users to provide a litany of personal
information including name date of birth
location email address home address and
products and activity preferences many
parents complained about this kind of
children's privacy violation and the FTC
at the time didn't feel like it had the
tools necessary to prevent this kind of
predatory practice against children when
Congress was considering Coppa the FTC
commissioner at the time robert Petoskey
testified to the quote particular
vulnerability of children and the
immediacy and ease with which
information can be collected from them
Coppa passed the House 333 to 95 and it
passed the Senate 65 to 29 and was
signed into law by President Clinton in
1998 the FTC has enforced penalties from
violations of Coppa least 30 times
ranging from companies like Gio city's
Lisa Frank Sony Yelp and many others but
let's first start with the actual
language of Coppa you can find the
statute at 15 USC Section 6502 that's
the section titled regulation of unfair
and deceptive acts and practices in
connection with collection and use of
personal information from and about
children on the Internet specifically
looking at subsection a 2 acts
prohibited in general it is unlawful for
an operator of a website or online
service directed to children or any
operator that has actual knowledge that
it is collecting personal information
from a child to collect personal
information from a child in a manner
that violates the regulations prescribed
under subsection B so in general what
this statute is saying is that any
operator of an online website or service
that is targeted to children cannot
collect personal information from a
child without parental consent and it's
also important to note that a child is
defined by the statute as someone who is
under the age of
thirteen so twelve years old and younger
now in Section 6501 Coppa defines the
term personal information and defines it
to mean individually identifiable
information about an individual
collected online including the first and
last name a home or other physical
address including street name name of a
city or town an email address a
telephone number a social security
number and importantly any other
identifiers that the Commission
determines permits the physical or
online contacting of a specific
individual now you've probably listened
to that statutory definition and thought
okay this all seems fine parents don't
want their children's to be contacted by
people online strangers or advertisers
and they certainly don't want their
children's social security numbers
publicized online but how does this
relate to YouTube it's not like YouTube
or creators are out there asking for
anyone's social security number or their
addresses let alone the addresses social
security numbers of children well the
thing that you need to understand about
American administrative agencies
including the FTC in this particular
case is that that they have what's
called rulemaking Authority under the
Administrative Procedures Act when
Congress passes a law they have neither
the time nor the inclination to cover
absolutely every eventualities it could
possibly happen so they empower federal
agencies to create rules that are under
the auspices of the general law that has
been passed and doesn't obviously
contradict that law but is sort of a
minor expansion of that law to cover
things that Congress might not have been
able to contemplate at the time that the
statute was passed and here the statute
specifically endowed the FTC with the
authority to expand the definition of
personal information to include other
things that the FTC believes that allows
a child to be contacted either
physically or online and there are
several terms that I mentioned just now
in those definitions that have big
implications based on the definition
that the FTC has adopted now what I read
to you previously that is the actual
coppiced a choot as passed by Congress
but the rules of the FTC has promulgated
over time are found in what's called the
Code of Federal Regulations the CFR for
short and the FTC promulgated new rules
about Coppa in 2013
in ways that had a drastic effect on how
Coppa interacts with YouTube 2013 is
when everything changed so let's look at
the rules that the FTC promulgated
specifically at 16 CFR 312 point 2 we
find the definition of the term operator
operator means any person who operates a
website located on the Internet or an
online service and who collects or
maintains personal information from or
about the users of or visitors to such
website or online service or on whose
behalf such information is collected or
maintained now that's important the FTC
in 2013 expanded the definition of
operator to include those on whose
behalf such personal information of
children was collected and that's why
Coppa now applies to YouTube creators
and YouTube channels because it's on
their behalf that YouTube collects that
personal information now in the same
section we find a definition of personal
information now this definition largely
tracks the definition that's found in
the statutory language of Coppa
including the address telephone number
and social security number of children
but what was new in 2013 was this new
definition of a persistent identifier
that did not exist prior to 2013 and
that is one of the most important rules
that the FTC promulgated in 2013 a
persistent identifier is something that
allows a website or service to track
individual users over time generally
this is found in the form of a cookie
it's a file that is placed on your
computer and watches your activity over
time it's the way that a website is able
to deliver personalized content to
individual users whether that's in the
form of a video that you want to see
based on your prior history of videos or
a specific ad based on products and
services that you were looking at
earlier before and in the context of
YouTube both of those things are true
it's the way that YouTube tracks your
viewing habits in order to give you a
video that you want to see based on your
prior viewing history and it's the way
that YouTube is able to get creators
paid because they're delivering targeted
ads to that particular audience and as a
result the ad rates that creators
receive is significantly higher than if
the ads were contextualized a
contextualized ad is sort of the
opposite of that it's based on the
substance of the
video as opposed to the prior behavior
of the audience so when kids are
watching Saturday morning cartoons and
you see a cartoon for GI Joe placed in
the middle of a GI Joe television show
well that's a contextualized ad some
people hate targeted ads and being
tracked online using cookies they see it
as a violation of the right to privacy
and other people really enjoy them
because they see content in the form of
advertisements that applies specifically
to them and thus it's a win-win for both
the advertiser and the viewer but the
bottom line is that YouTube can't really
function without persistent identifiers
the algorithm the YouTube algorithm
itself would not exist if not for the
invention of persistent identifiers it
allows YouTube to show content to people
that they want to see because of an
algorithm that is based on their prior
behavior without persistent identifiers
the YouTube algorithm doesn't work and
YouTube as a platform probably doesn't
exist and in 2013 the FTC changed the
rule so that YouTube could no longer use
persistent identifiers with respect to
children remember anyone under the age
of 13 persistent identifiers are totally
off the table and in theory that
shouldn't affect the user experience of
adults but we'll talk about in a few
minutes how that theory doesn't really
meet practice unfortunately and it does
affect adults now before we leave
section 3 12.2 let's talk about how
Coppa is triggered there are two ways to
trigger Coppa one is that you create
content that is child directed or two
you have actual knowledge that children
are using your online service or website
so let's talk about the first
requirement that something is child
directed the section states that a
website or online service directed to
children means a commercial website or
online service or portion thereof that
is targeted to children in determining
whether a website or online service or a
portion thereof is directed to children
the Commission will consider its subject
matter visual content use of animated
characters or child oriented activities
and incentives music or other audio
content age of models presence of child
celebrities or celebrities who appeal to
children language or other
characteristics of the website or online
service as well as whether advertising
promoting or appearing on the website or
online service is directed to children
the Commission will also
consider competent and reliable
empirical evidence regarding audience
compositions and evidence regarding the
intended audience the ten factor
analysis is purposefully written vaguely
that vagueness provides flexibility
unfortunately it also provides
uncertainty but the important thing to
remember is that it's not a checklist
you can't simply say that okay you have
checked off factors one through four but
not factors five through ten and as a
result it's not child directed you have
to weigh them so the good news is that
say for example if you have an animation
channel just because it mentions
animated characters that doesn't mean
you are per se a child directed channel
and it's also conceivable that you might
meet all of the factors in this test
except for let's say the first fact
you're talking about the subject matter
of the particular video and it's
possible that the subject matter is so
adult that it counteracts meeting all of
the other factors are having an example
of some of those factors so conceivably
there could be a video out there that is
adult themed but happens to check all of
the other boxes like there is a child
celebrity there or there is childish
music and there's animated characters
but the fact that it is so adult
oriented counteracts all of the other
factors so that's the point of having
the flexibility of this ten factor test
is that you have to weigh each one with
the other factors and just because you
meet some of the factors it doesn't mean
that you are automatically shunted into
the child directed category you have to
holistically weigh all of them against
each other so in terms of child directed
its intended to be a proxy for the
intent of the author does the author
intend this material this online service
or videos for children people under the
age of 13
of course the FTC would have a really
hard time trying to figure out the
intent of the author
so they created these ten or so factors
that are objective in nature you can
look to the website or the video itself
and you can run through these factors
and actually get an idea for whether
these factors are press
or they're missing so these 10 factors
are what would allow the FTC to make a
judgment call as to whether a particular
YouTube channel is in fact
child-directed or not now the other way
for Coppa to be triggered if you are a
content creator is if you have actual
knowledge that children are using your
website or watching your videos
this section states that a website or
online service shall be deemed directed
to children when it has actual knowledge
that it is collecting personal
information directly from users of
another website or online service
directed to children so for example if
someone left a comment on your video
that says I am a 10 year old child and
you read that comment you might have
actual knowledge that children are
watching your content of course YouTube
would probably ban that person
immediately because they then have also
actual knowledge that child is using
their website and YouTube is directed
for only people above the age of 13 but
still that is one way to get actual
knowledge that children are using your
site or watching your videos and
importantly handing off your iPad from
an adult to a child does not qualify as
verified consent now that brings us to
the so-called mixed audience exception
what if you are Major League Baseball
and you know that adults watch your
videos but they also know that children
watch those videos to the fact that one
child might be watching a video does
that mean that suddenly your video is a
child directed well maybe maybe not
under this section a website or online
service that is directed to children
under the criteria set forth in
paragraph 1 which we already talked
about but that does not target children
as its primary audience shall not be
deemed to be directed to children if one
it does not collect personal information
from any visitor prior to collecting age
information and to prevents the
collection use or disclosure of personal
information from visitors who identify
themselves as under age 13 without first
complying with the notice and parental
consent provisions of this part so the
mixed audience exception is not as
simple as saying that the intended
audience of this video is not primarily
children it's that but you also have to
prove that you are no longer using
persistent identifiers of children and
that you are getting age information
before allowing people to view that
content and because of the way that
YouTube is set up it is not
that any particular youtuber can avail
themselves of this exception on the
other hand the argument can be made that
because individual creators are not
using persistent identifiers and they
rely on the general YouTube platform
which is itself a jaded in that you
can't create a YouTube account without
verifying that you are over the age of
12 that perhaps individual creators can
avail themselves of the mixed audience
exception that they know whether their
intended audience is primarily children
or not which meets the first-level
criteria of the mixed audience exception
and given the way that the YouTube
system is set up that is now explicitly
segregating between child audiences and
non child audiences that may be the
mixed audience exception does apply and
if that is the case it does make sense
that there isn't sort of a third option
when you're uploading a video because
instead of having three options between
child directed not child directed and
mixed remember the mixed audience
exception is an exception to child
directed so if the mixed audience
exception applies you would simply check
the box when you're uploading a video
that says not child directed because
mixed audience is an exception to the
child directed standard but that's
something that requires clarification
from the FTC and YouTube now we'll talk
about the mixed audience exception at
length in just a moment but suffice to
say it's not the Savior that some people
think it is so given that in a second
I'm going to talk about whether your
particular channel or your particular
video qualifies as directed to children
or whether the mixed audience exception
may apply in your particular case but
before we get there well we're still
talking about the more technical aspects
of it I want to talk about the
repercussions of what happens if your
content is considered directed at
children well we've already talked about
how YouTube cannot use persistent
identifiers cookies or IP addresses to
track children so when a video is
considered directed at children YouTube
has to effectively shut off the
algorithm it can't recommend that video
and it also can't use targeted ads for
that particular video because that would
be targeting the user
it's not clear exactly how less
profitable contextualized ads compared
to targeted ads are but by all accounts
contextualized ads probably bring one
tenth of the ad revenue of a targeted ad
so that means that people who create
kids content might see their Adsense
fall to one tenth of the current levels
but it also means that YouTube has to
effectively shut off any conduit for
personalized information from being
created on the video that means that
YouTube has to shut off all the comments
on the video that video can have no info
cards or end screens no recommendations
no notifications no use of the community
tab and no stories on YouTube for that
particular channel of the whole channel
is considered a kids directed channel
remember so much of what makes YouTube
work is the persistent identifiers in
conjunction with the YouTube algorithm
and that's simply off-limits for both
children as an audience and content that
is considered directed at children now
YouTube is taking the position that when
a piece of content is labeled as child
directed YouTube will assume that the
entire audience is children regardless
of whether they have verified that one
of those people could be an adult they
will turn off all the comments that turn
off notifications and you can't use
persistent identifiers or benefit from
the YouTube algorithm now theoretically
you can use all of this information you
just need to have parental consent
unfortunately the parental consent
provisions in Coppa are incredibly
onerous and are very unlikely to
actually be used in real life so let's
talk about the big question how do you
know if your particular video or channel
is considered directed at children well
we've already talked about the ten
factors that the FTC considers the
consent order that YouTube had to sign
as a settlement of the FTC complaint
against it has a modified version of the
ten factors that you find in the CFR
specifically subject matter visual
content use of animated characters music
age of models presence of child
celebrities celebrities who appeal to
children language now the
characteristics advertising promoting
the website and competent reliable
empirical evidence regarding so those
are the ten fact
the creators are going to have to use to
analyze their particular content to
determine if their content is considered
child directed or not remember those
factors are supposed to be a proxy for
the intent of the creator but because
the factors are relatively objective
effectively the FTC could disagree even
if you had a bonafide true belief that
your content was not directed at
children
the FTC could use those 10 factors to
disagree with your own intent and to
find that your content is in fact child
directed but because these are ten
factors that means that there is going
to have to be some kind of balancing
when there is a factor based test you
know that all of these different
elements are going to come into
consideration odds are they're not gonna
go after some creator with a small
number of subscribers and something
that's a close call but still
theoretically the FTC could do that now
sometimes factors are more important
than others and we have no guidance from
the FTC as to which particular factors
they may weigh heavier than other ones
but we can be sure that probably none of
these factors acts as a per se
indication that any Content is directed
at children for example I've been
hearing a lot of creators who have
animated channels being worried that
because their channel is animated that
they are necessarily going to be
considered child directed and I don't
think that's accurate
even though animation is a factor in
these ten factors you would have to
weigh the fact that a channel is
animated with the fact that they're
dealing with adult subject matter and
you'd have to weigh that against all of
the other ten different factors so for
example odd ones out often does very
adult themes on their channel despite
being considered animated I probably
would not consider that channel to be
child directed that's just my own
opinion reasonable minds may differ but
the bottom line is that these are
factors and they have to be weighed it's
likely that none of these are going to
be dispositive so I wouldn't necessarily
worry that if your channel uses music
for example or your channel happens to
have some animation in it that per say
you have a child directed video but it's
problematic because we have no
guidance from the FTC as to how we are
supposed to weigh these different
factors and if something is more
important than the others it's also
problematic because often creators don't
know the audience that they have YouTube
often doesn't provide some of these
statistics including for example people
who are under 13 years of age and even
if you did know the makeup of your
audience right down to exactly how many
children versus 18 versus 30 year olds
we're watching your content the FTC also
has purposefully never created a
bright-line rule with respect to how
many children tips the balance into
making your channel child directed the
tenth factor appears to to look at the
empirical evidence of who's watching
your channel but let's say your channel
has one child does that tip the balance
does that make your video child directed
if you had 25% of your audience is that
child directed 50% 75% in some ways it's
good that we don't have this bright-line
rule because it allows for flexibility
but at the same time that flexibility
also creates uncertainty as well so in a
second I'm going to talk about the mixed
audience exception in great detail and
I'm gonna talk about what creators might
do if they make child directed content
or they have a channel that has followed
both by adults and children at the same
time the FTC says that individual
YouTube creators are responsible for
knowing whether their content is child
directed or not and it is the
responsibility of individual creators to
make that designation on their videos
and on their channel at large and
theoretically if a creator gets that
wrong and they label something that is
child directed as not child directed
then they could be fined by the FTC now
practically speaking the FTC doesn't
have all that many funds they have only
enforced Coppa a handful of times over
the years but still the fact remains
that they can go out and sue individual
creators and they've said as much that
they intend to do so
the FTC loves to talk about clear-cut
examples when you push them they give
the example of Peppa Pig of something
that is so clearly child directed that
it's obvious that you should label it as
child directed and then conversely they
would talk about something that is not
made for
like Call of Duty or streaming scenes
from Call of Duty and that's fine that's
just as well but the world is rife with
examples that fall somewhere in the
middle and there's never been a
particularly clear-cut line of what to
do with those kind of examples consider
PewDiePie ER or matpat who have probably
an audience that is the majority of
adults if not at least people over the
age of 12 but still odds are that part
of that audience is children they can't
point to any particular audience member
being a child probably but when you have
a hundred million subscribers odds are
there's conservatively millions of
children who are in your audience and
not to mention sports examples like
baseball or WWE where the main intended
audience is probably adults but it is
well known that children love to watch
sports as well and even some of the
FTC's clear examples aren't particularly
that clear think about Pokemon for
example that is clearly a child directed
video game or at least it was when it
started but now there is an entire
generation of people who grew up playing
pokemon and still play it for nostalgia
reasons and also because they enjoy
playing the video game itself writ large
is Pokemon live streaming for adults
serve for children to understand what
creators should do we first have to
understand how we got here and
specifically we have to understand how
YouTube has responded to the FTC
complaint and the 170 million dollar
fine that was levied against them at
base in 2018 a complaint was filed
before the FTC by 23 different advocacy
groups for children privacy and
consumers the complaint alleged
years-long violations of Coppa and
millions of dollars in revenue resulting
from the collection and use of personal
data from children and also alleged that
YouTube is the most popular online
platform for children and then 80% of US
children use the site daily and that it
will soon surpass traditional television
as the most-watched video format for
children YouTube countered that YouTube
main has always been for people 13 years
and older and that they created YouTube
kids specifically as a sandbox for
children under the age of 13 the FTC has
always claimed that that's completely
inadequate however because children can
simply lie and claim that they're older
than 13 years old as we know many
children do and get access to YouTube
vain and when a child lies YouTube then
uses persistent identifiers for children
it may not be YouTube's fault but they
are using persistent identifiers for
children that are lying about their age
and on top of that YouTube in their
marketing materials was actually
bragging to all kinds of advertisers
that they knew that lots and lots of
children were using YouTube main so the
FTC argued that YouTube had actual
knowledge that children were using the
site and in fact they were touting that
as an advantage to advertisers so after
litigation and negotiations YouTube
entered into a stipulated settlement
with the FTC Google agreed to pay a
historically large 170 million dollar
fine a fine that is ten times larger
than all of the previous Coppa fines
combined the settlement or consent
decree requires YouTube to develop a
system that allows channel owners to
identify their child oriented content
YouTube must also notify channel owners
that their content is subject to Coppa
compliance and must also provide annual
training to its employees who interact
with YouTube channel owners YouTube must
also provide data to the FTC about their
data collection practices and obtain
verifiable parental consent before
collecting personal data from children
channel owners also are required to do a
number of things under the consent
decree including they must make a clear
and conspicuous disclosure that the
channel or content is directed at
children on September 4th YouTube issued
a blog post indicating that it intended
to comply with the FTC order by assuming
that all viewers of child oriented
videos are children rather than trying
to identify individual viewers and
determining their age effectively
because the FTC says that if you can't
trust the general 13-plus age gait or
swing gate to access YouTube main then
YouTube would have to do that and as we
talked about previously YouTube is going
to remove personalized ads and features
like comments and notifications from
content that is considered directed at
children and on top of that YouTube is
going to try to develop a machine
learning system that will be
able to determine what content is
considered child directed despite the
certifications of the individual
creators now as I sit there are two big
issues that are going to have drastic
repercussions for content creators as a
result of both the FTC prosecution and
the way that YouTube is deciding to
implement solutions to the FTC complaint
now the first is that the FTC
is not allowing YouTube to have a sort
of generalized age Gate YouTube main is
for people that are over 13 years old
effectively if the FTC is punishing
YouTube for children lying about their
age and preventing YouTube from using a
general age gate in that respect that
has huge repercussions for all creators
effectively then the default is to
assume that anyone who uses YouTube is a
child unless you have verified that they
are an adult that puts huge barriers on
all creators and YouTube itself if the
FTC's position is that you can't trust
the certification of the user when they
say they're over the age of 13 that
could mean that the default position is
that Coppa applies to anything
imagine if adults had to certify and
show their driver's license to prove
that they're over the age of 13 to be
able to access YouTube main the
overzealous application of Coppa puts
burdens on adults and actually starts
running into some constitutional issues
that we'll talk about in a second but
admittedly these are not easy questions
what about accounts that aren't signed
in who do we assume they are what about
shared devices between adults and
children what about parents who actively
give their iPad to a child to watch and
that brings me to the second problem
which i think is a response to the first
and that is that YouTube in response to
the FTC demands is saying that any
Content that is considered child
directed in any way it loses access to
the algorithm to persistent identifier
to targeted ads to comments
notifications stories all of that is
gone but what about the use case of say
an adult that comments on a video that
is quote directed to children now
certainly we can't have children
commenting on videos under Coppa and we
can't have children being tracked using
persistent identifiers but you might
imagine that that is trackable on the
individual level if we know that a user
is a child then we can just simply turn
off those features for the child but let
me give you an example imagine there's a
family vlog and the parents are watching
this family vlog well the parents might
want to make comments on the family vlog
and make comments with other parents or
you might be watching baseball and we
know that children like watching
baseball as well and adults might want
to make comments about the baseball game
unfortunately if YouTube determines that
any content is considered child directed
all of those features are turned off
regardless of whether that person is an
adult or not so even though Coppa is
directed only at children adults are
being affected if the content is
considered child directed YouTube is
taking the blanket position that adults
are going to be treated like children as
well that's certainly the safe position
for YouTube maybe the overly cautious
position but from where I stand that's a
huge loss to many communities and many
adults of course it's easy for me to say
that I'm not the one that was fined 170
million dollars and I don't run a child
directed channel so with that background
let's talk about the question that's on
everyone's mind what happens to your
channel if you think that your audiences
in whole or in part children or you
think that your content may qualify as
child directed well what happens to your
channel depends on what kind of channel
you have there are three different
buckets that we need to talk about one
is a creator who directs content to kids
under the age of 13 one is a creator who
directs content to both and third is the
creator who never directs any content to
children has a very very small number of
children who watch their content so if
you make child directed content and for
the sake of argument let's assume that
that means more than 51% of your
audience is children or whether you are
specifically targeting that demographic
though those are not the actual
standards that the FTC may or may not
adopt as we've talked about YouTube
effectively has to shut off the
algorithm that means no targeted ads at
best you're going to be dealing with
contextualized ads it means no comments
it means no info cards
or n screens and recommendations
notifications you can't use the
community tab can't use stories and if
the FTC disagrees with your designation
you could theoretically be fined forty
two thousand five hundred and thirty
dollars for each violation that being
said the FTC doesn't have all that many
funds to go after violations of Coppa
they've only enforced it a handful of
times over the years and we've never
seen any YouTube creators so far been
prosecuted though the FCC has
specifically said that they could go
after YouTube creators YouTube said it's
going to invest heavily in YouTube kids
but it remains to be seen what kind of
improvements are going to be made to
that and how they're going to make up
for the lost ad revenue from the lack of
personalized ads so we can think about
whether your video falls into the
category of child directed as sort of a
flowchart you might ask yourself three
questions to determine if your content
is child directed the first is did you
intend your content for children the
second is do you have actual knowledge
of children watching your content or
Channel and the third is do you think
that your content falls into the
category of child directed based on a
balancing of the ten factors as laid out
in the statue if you answered yes to any
of those questions then your content is
considered child directed however even
if your content is considered child
directed you can get out of that
category if the mixed audience exception
applies which means that number one the
primary audience that you are directing
your content is not children and you
meet the requirements for subsections 1
and 2 of the mixed audience exception
and as I talked about earlier it's an
open question if any creator can meet
those requirements so that takes us to a
creator who has a mixed audience now
remember there are two different things
that we need to talk about here number
one is just because a channel has an
audience that has some component of
children in it doesn't necessarily mean
that the channel itself is child
directed so remember in the first
instance you have to go through that ten
factor analysis to determine if the FTC
would consider your content to be child
directed or also copy can be triggered
if you
actual knowledge the kids are watching
your content or using your services so
if you run through that ten factor
analysis and you say okay factor number
one this is an adult subject matter I
don't have any child celebrities I don't
have music that would be attractive to
children and you determine that your
content is not child directed as based
on those factors then you might not fit
in this bucket at all but if you feel
that under that ten factor analysis your
content might be considered child
directed or do you have actual knowledge
that children are watching your videos
then you would need to rely on the mixed
audience exception the mixed audience
exception recognizes that some services
and videos are appealing to both
children and non children alike and as a
result it allows content creators to get
out of that box of child directed if
they meet certain requirements the so
called mixed audience exception is found
in Section 312 point two again and
States specifically then a website or
online service that is directed to
children under this criteria set forth
in paragraph one that's the ten factors
we talked about but that does not target
children as its primary audience shall
not be deemed directed to children if
one it does not collect personal
information from any visitor prior to
collecting age information and to
prevents the collection use or
disclosure of personal information from
visitors who identify themselves as
under the age of thirteen without first
complying with a notice and parental
consent provisions of this part now some
commentators including my friend and
fellow lawyer
Ian Corzine have argued that YouTube is
hiding the ball by not explaining to
creators that the mixed audience
exception exists and by not making the
mixed audience exception an option when
you're uploading a video unfortunately I
don't think that that's really true and
here's why remember that the mixed
audience exception applies only when
number one your primary audience is not
children but also it has two additional
requirements regarding personal
information it means that operators and
remember YouTube creators are operators
under Coppa now cannot collect personal
information from visitors prior to
collecting age information and that they
prevent the use of personal information
from visitors
who identify themselves as under the age
of 13
now you might assume that you could just
rely on the general YouTube age gate and
the fact that YouTube is actively
segregating users based on their age
they put children in YouTube kids and
they put everybody else in YouTube's
main but the problem is that the FTC
appears to be taking the position that
YouTube with let alone creators cannot
rely on the overall age gaiter sometimes
call the swing gate in terms of assuming
that people who are using YouTube main
are over the age of 13 and on top of
that if you put an age gate on every
single video and required people to
affirmative ly state that they are over
the age of 13 before they watched any
video that is marked as not directed at
children well number one you're putting
a burden on adults which is sort of an
iffy area but if YouTube can't rely on
their general age gate in the Terms of
Service it says no one under the age of
13 can use YouTube's main then why would
the FTC take their word on an age gate
on any particular video remember that to
sign up for YouTube in the first place
you have to certify that you are over
the age of 13 and if you put in a birth
date that is below that you will be
rejected from creating a YouTube account
and if that's not good enough for the
FTC then the only thing that YouTube can
do is what they're doing that
effectively there is no mixed audience
exception if anything is considered
child directed then they have to turn
off the algorithm they have to turn off
comments and we are limited in to
stating that a video is either directed
at children or it is not directed at
children and in a way children are
getting a veto on adult behavior YouTube
may have to take the position that for a
child directed video or a partially
child directed video they have to remove
all persistent identifiers whether the
audience is children or adults now it's
unclear if this is required when Malik
Ducard
of YouTube spoke to the FTC in October
this is one of the things that he really
wanted clarification from the FTC but
for the time being the mixed audience
exception is up in the air it's not
clear that either YouTube or YouTube
creators will ever be able to meet the
requirements depending on how strictly
the FTC is interpreting their rules and
it's unclear who if anyone can take
advantage of the mixed audience
exception so what are the consequences
of Coppa in this context well we can
probably be sure that some people are
gonna make less content some people are
going to be too afraid of the
regulations of potential fines we've
already seen people delete their entire
channels we've seen some people take
their content behind paywalls and some
will lose monetization entirely while
others see maybe a tenth of their
adsense as they have to deal with
contextualized ads instead of
personalized ads and in some instances
the FTC has said that the alternative to
not using persistent identifiers is to
remove the videos entirely that's what
tik-tok had to do when they got hit with
nearly six million dollar fine for
almost these exact same copy violations
and there are other unintended
consequences of Coppa one of the biggest
ironies is that platforms may now be
required to collect more data on their
users not less it forces apps and
platforms and websites to get more info
about their audience about their age and
be able to enforce these different age
gates we can probably also be sure that
some of the Machine flagged videos are
gonna be false positives and who knows
if individual creators are going to be
able to appeal a decision that a video
is marked as child directed when they
had no intent of directing their videos
to children of course as a lawyer I
can't help but wonder if this whole
enforcement action is legal in the first
place as I mentioned earlier I think
there may be some constitutional issues
here I wouldn't necessarily hang my hat
on these arguments but thinking out loud
I can think of some things that may be
problematic for the way that the FTC is
handling this first as I mentioned
before the way that this is being
enforced basically restricts content
based on viewpoints and the intended
audience and when you are restricting
speech based on viewpoint you run into
some First Amendment issues and I
wouldn't say that this necessarily
applies but there is a notion in first
a law about a hecklers veto that you see
this a lot in college campuses that just
because someone is going to protest and
that protests may spawn violent counter
protests you don't allow the violent
counter protests to stifle the original
protest that's called a hecklers veto
and if we consider child-directed to be
the lowest common denominator
effectively that has stifled regular
speech that's the hecklers veto and by
analogy if we said that content that was
viewed by let's say twenty five percent
of children was enough to trigger Coppa
then that minority of children that
watched this content have then placed
huge burdens on that content with
respect to everybody else who are not
children it's sort of like a child's
hecklers veto and let's not forget the
children have free speech rights too in
Brown versus Entertainment Merchants
Association decided in 2011 the Supreme
Court struck down a 2005 California law
which banned the sale of certain violent
video games to children without parental
supervision just because we're dealing
with children doesn't mean that they
lack First Amendment protections as well
fellow YouTube lawyer Jeremy Johnston
thinks that this law may be
unconstitutionally vague based on the 10
factor analysis that may be the case I
have my doubts but it's an interesting
argument and there's an open question as
to whether the FTC has exceeded its
regulatory authority we looked at the
original statutory language and there's
a big difference between a child's
social security number and the new
definition of personal information which
includes persistent identifiers now
admittedly regulatory authorities
receive what's called Chevron deference
which means that courts are very
unlikely to overrule the rule making of
various agencies but at least
theoretically they are still bound by
the language of the statute itself now I
regret to inform you that unfortunately
this situation can get worst the last
rule review for the FTC was in 2013 that
is what put in place these new
definitions that we are just now
grappling with but those definitions
could get even worse there is a big
movement to expand the thirteen-year-old
cutoff to even later maybe 15 16
year-old to expand Coppa to apply to
teenage
as well as children under the age of 13
there's a big push to expand Coppa past
child directed to include child
attractive so that regardless of what
your intent was if really any children
are attracted to your content then it's
considered child directed as well the
170 million dollar fine that YouTube had
to pay as part of the consent decree was
only approved by the FTC as three to two
split amongst the commissioners the
other commissioners wanted to make the
find much much worse and put in place
much more draconian procedures so things
can get worse before they get better but
that raises the question what can we do
well whether you are a YouTube creator
whether you are a fan of other creators
there's a lot that can still be done
first of all leave comments with the FTC
everyone has until December 9th 2019 to
leave comments with the FTC I'll leave
some links in the description for where
you can leave those comments and some
suggestions as to what kind of wording
you should leave with the FTC big thanks
to Jeremy Johnston who put all of that
together who has spoken to the FTC and
has really been the tip of the spear
when it comes to creating this movement
among creators recognizing the danger
and recognizing that we need to reach
out to the FTC I will say don't be rude
to the FTC don't call them names don't
use profanity it's going to be some poor
staffer that reads all of these comments
but the more cons that we can leave the
better I also reach out to the FTC
commissioners on Twitter I'll leave some
links to their Twitter handles don't
just limit yourself to the FTC comment
system itself reach out via Twitter as
well make your voices known additionally
reach out to your legislators as well
they can put pressure on the FTC their
voices would be welcome in this as well
and in terms of feedback explain how cop
is going to lead to less content that
it's too much of a risk for individual
creators that it's making it not
monetarily feasible for many of the
smaller channels out there explain that
the mixed audience exception needs to be
expanded to make sure that the creators
are safe regardless of what the FTC may
decide on an ad hoc basis explain how
the YouTube system
works in that the age gate should be
sufficient and that is not fair to treat
adults like children that we should
allow adults to be treated like adults
explain that YouTube kids is a great
place for kids and for parents that want
to take their kids out of YouTube main
it presents a great alternative and also
that we should expand the ability of
parents to be able to consent if a
parent hands off their device to a child
and allows them to use YouTube main that
should be considered a form of parental
consent which is not currently
recognized by Cobham explain that based
on the way that the internet works using
persistent identifies as a form of PII
for children doesn't make any sense and
that the definition of personal
information should not include
persistent identifiers or that
persistent identifiers should be treated
differently and for more information I
would recommend checking out Jeremy
Johnston and Ian Corzine's channel for
the opinion of two other great lawyers
now for better or worse cop is just one
of the many issues that creators need to
deal with online and while it's not
great the thing that stares graters the
most is usually copyright and that's why
I created copyright course comm to give
all creators the tools they need to be
able to deal with copyright online and
use copyrighted material in a fair use
way you can use the link in the
description to get 10% off of copyright
course and copyright coarse premium but
only for the next 30 days because the
fat cats in Hollywood have hundreds of
corporate lawyers that deal with this
stuff all day long what do online
creators have I've represented movie
studios directors actors writers and
artists individuals and multi-billion
dollar corporations
and I think it's time to give even the
smallest creator the tools that the big
guys have had for years and maybe you
want to make youtube videos but are
afraid of doing something wrong maybe
you already make videos but have seen a
big music label monetize that video
maybe you want to enforce your rights
online maybe you've been hit with a
takedown notice and can't figure out how
to challenge it whatever stage you're at
the copyright course will give you the
confidence to create what you want and
the knowledge to beat bogus attacks on
your content copyright course distills
everything I know about u.s. copyright
law including the major legal concepts
and practical advice for how you can use
the law to defend your content
trolls and copyright course premium even
gives you written templates based on the
actual legal arguments that I have used
to defend my channel against dozens of
bogus copyright claims just click on the
link in the description or go to
copyright course comm to learn how to
make copyright work for you so do you
agree with my analysis are you worried
about Coppa leave your objections in the
comments and check out my other real law
reviews over here in this playlist where
I'll see you in court